you were talking earlier on about the
fact that dopamine can be released when
you set yourself a little goal and then
achieve it and one of the ways that you
encourage your grad students is to give
them a little bit of reward earlier on
so that it keeps them motivated is this
the same mentality that works during an
endurance event when you want to say i'm
just going to get myself to the next
lamppost so i've just got to get myself
to that hill over there is that the same
dynamic yeah we can call it milestoning
you just set some milestone and the key
thing here is that and this is the
beauty of the dopamine system
just like the stress system is generic
the fear system is generic it's designed
for a bunch of different scenarios the
motivation system is also generic
it can be
to achieve the next lamp post as a
milestone or it can be five miles is the
next milestone you get to control that
and it so it's completely arbitrary
right i mean one of the most brilliant
things that was ever said to me by an
extremely skilled psychoanalyst
is so simple and yet i do think it's the
most fundamental thing to understanding
oneself is that it's all internal
right if you finish a marathon in first
place no one comes along and drips
dopamine in your ear you self-generate
that it's all internal it's all about
your internal representation now that
doesn't mean that there aren't good and
bad events in life but
the fact of the matter is that if you
set the next milestone as
just outside the distance of what you're
comfortable with and you make it there
if you allow yourself a moment to
register that win
you get energy to do to then set the
next milestone and achieve it that
energy is dopamine converted into
epinephrine into adrenaline and this is
why you hear these incredible heroic
stories like i mean i think the movie
sorry i i hate to say it but the movie
was less good than the book but like
lone survivor the marcus latrell story
and the actually i think today or
yesterday might be the anniversary of
operation red wings so all those guys
sadly died except
marcus
and you know he in the movie he sort of
it's like fast forward to where he i
don't want to give it away but where he
basically is the lone survivor but
in the book it's crazy i mean the guy
dragged himself on elbows and knees for
miles and miles and miles right you know
that kind of ability where you hear
about people walking on stubs to you
know these incredible feats of human
um
endurance and willingness to persist
i mean
those
people were able to do that not because
of glycogen or they drank their goo or
whatever the triathletes are always
using it's because of
nervous system
energy the ability to continue to
manufacture adrenaline and keep going
and the and the extent to which that can
continue is no one will ever know i do
believe that humans have a tremendous
capacity to endure and persist
but that few human beings actually know
how to tap into that system except under
conditions of extreme survival and you
also hear from
really good physicians ones that aren't
into woo biology or woo psychology at
all that to some extent yes there are
people that unfortunately die in their
battle against cancer no matter what but
that the
the desire to continue living is a
powerful force in of itself
there may be spiritual components there
may be that's not the business i'm in
you know so and how i don't know the
experiment i would do to test it but
almost certainly setting of milestones
and the ability to generate dopamine and
adrenaline is what allows people to
persist and live longer there's no
question about that what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you